we knew from a rigging point of view and
from an armature point of view we wanted
to make this thing as light as possible
because we knew that we'd be fighting
the scale and the weight as we started
work it out we figured that no this
thing is really just a giant puppet and
so we applied the same principles that
we would apply to any puppet but just on
a big scale we're picking the elbow and
the wrist up with cables instead of
having mechanical shoulder who have
magnificent shoulder and that allows us
to roll the solo we know lots of ranked
working with the giant skeleton was sort
of an animators worst nightmare
we puff it is bigger than you are and it
was intimidating how are we going to
manage this huge thing not to mention a
scary-looking all the end [ __ ] here
I'm sure used to working with puppets
anywhere from 6 to 15 inches tall this
has a whole new set of different
difficulties access physical space wait
so it was really physically demanding
the slow date would be 8 frames a day in
12 hours that's like over an hour of
frame fasting 18 frames thank goodness
that's over